So I was saying in my upbringing as a
former Muslim we grew up thinking
everything in terms of like sort of a
financial way like the good deeds you do
and then say you add the bad things you
don't do. So so as as a Christian what
motivates a Christian to keep doing good
things and when people go to heaven are
they rewarded differently for different
things they've done or that's something
I'm trying to study and understand.
>> The love of Christ motivates us to do
good things.
John 15:es 9-10.
John 15:es 9 to10.
Let me show you. The love of Christ
motivates us to do things. As the father
loved me, I also have loved you. Abide
in my love. If you keep my commandments,
you will abide in my love, just as I've
kept my father's commandments and abide
in his love. John 14
21. John 14:21. John 14:15 first. Let's
go to John 14:15.
>> Okay.
>> John 14:15 first. He who has my
commandments and keeps them. It is he
who loves me, and he who loves me will
be loved by my father, and I will love
him and manifest myself to him. John
14:23-24.
Jesus answered and said to him, "If
anyone loves me, he will keep my word,
and my father will love him, and we will
come to him and make our home with him.
He who does not love me does not keep my
words. And the word which you hear is
not mine, but the father's who sent me."
And then 2 Corinthians 5:14.
Why do I keep his commands? Because I
love Jesus. If I love Jesus, I'll keep
his commands. If I don't, I won't. 2
Corinthians 5:14. 2 Corinthians 5:14.
For the love of Christ compels us. The
love of Christ compels us. Let me repeat
it again. What compels me to do what I
do? His love for me. The love of Christ
compels us because we judge thus that if
one died for all, then all died. That
answered that question, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's interesting. You don't
look at it in a transactional way.
You're very
>> Why would I? You're well well I I I'm
I'm saying it as in like just how
different it is from how a Muslim thinks
about it.
>> Yeah. Now
>> it's just it's very transactional.
>> But because God is a gracious God and a
good God, he will then reward you for
loving him and obeying him. In other
words, God is not obligated to give you
a reward. And that's your attitude. Your
attitude should be, I don't deserve a
reward for doing what's my duty. My duty
is to love God and serve God and obey
God because he's my life. I exist for
him. And once you have that attitude,
God says, "That's the attitude I want
you to have. Yet, nonetheless, I will
still reward you anyway for doing what
is your duty." Let me show you that. Are
you ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Luke 17 7-10. Luke 17 to10.
I hope everyone else got what I just
said. Luke 17 and 10. Here's what Jesus
said your attitude should be. Here's
what Jesus said your attitude should be
when you do what you're supposed to do
as a servant, pay attention and read.
But okay. And which of you having a
servant plowing or tending sheep will
say to him when he has come in from the
field, come at once and sit down and
eat. But will he not rather say to him,
"Prepare something for my supper and
gird yourself and serve me till I have
eaten and drunk. And afterward you will
eat and drink." Now watch here. Eat and
drink. Now watch what he says here.
Does he thank the servant because he did
the things that were commanded him? I
think not. I don't think thank the
servant for doing what is his duty. So
notice verse 10. Jesus speaking to all
of us. So likewise you speaking to you
and me now today although initially was
his disciples. you when you have done
all those things which you are commanded
say this is your attitude Christians we
are unprofitable servants we have done
what was our duty to do you see what
Jesus said you don't do something
because you expect the reward that's a
rotten attitude you do it because you're
obligated to do it because you exist for
me you're my servants I'm the reason why
you exist I'm the reason why you live
and you live for me so do what's
required of you once you have that
attitude. Jesus says, "Now I will reward
you."
>> That sink in.
>> So wouldn't would that wouldn't that be
a good argument against people who say
all you need is just faith and that's
that's all?
>> Yeah. Because true faith is something
that has to transform you by the spirit
to obey and love Christ. It's like
saying,
"I love my wife, but I cheat on her.
I love my wife, but I don't spend time
with her. I love my wife, but I cuss her
out and disrespect her. I love my wife,
but I abandon her and don't provide her
daily needs. You know what the wife will
say, right? Take that love and shove it.
Why do I use the why did I use the
analogy of wife? Because Jesus describes
himself as a husband to a wife. We are
the bride. He is the husband. Our
husband has proven his love for us to
the point he died for us. What have we
done to show that we truly love him and
are paying lip service
>> is to do what we are ordered to do.
>> In other words, let me explain what the
Bible is. It's not a transaction for
goods and payment. It's a covenant that
binds people to intimate communion and
love. Loving the other and living for
the other and the pleasure of the other.
That's what a covenant is biblically.
See, the difference is it's a covenant,
not a transgression, a transaction for
goods,
for items, right? No, that's not it's a
covenant. And a covenant entails parties
coming together, binding themselves to
the other to seek the pleasure of the
other and the happiness of the other. So
if I live live up to the end of my
bargain, my bargain is to make you
happy. Mhm.
>> Make sure that you are delighted seeking
your pleasure. Vice versa. So if you
live up to your end of the bargain,
you're going to make me happy. And if
I'm living up to the end of my mark
bargain, I'll be making you happy. So
we're going to make the other happy. So
as I try to make you happy, you try to
make me happy. We'll always be happy. No
one's going to be upset. No one's going
to be hurt. No one's going to be
disappointed. The sad reality is God has
gone out of his way to love us and bless
us and give us pleasure and joy and the
our daily needs. We're the ones who are
failing on our part of the bargain.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's the answer, brother.
>> Okay. Thank you. So, so in terms of in
terms of what a person gets in heaven,
is there sort of like a like a hierarchy
place in Islam where there's this first
heaven, the other one?
>> Well, no, no, no.
Don't think of heavens as where I'll be
in the third heaven, you'll be in the
first heaven.
>> There is ranking rewards.
Rewards meaning you will have a higher
level of authority over someone else.
Jesus said that, didn't he? Matthew
5:19. Whoever therefore breaks one of
the least of these commandments and
teaches men so shall, and we're waiting
for the rest of the verse. Sorry about
that, brother. Shall be called least in
the kingdom of heaven. Whatever does and
teaches them, he shall be called great
in the kingdom of heaven. Right?
>> So you have least and you have great in
the kingdom. Matthew 11.
Assuredly I say to you, among those born
of women, there has not risen one
greater than John the Baptist, but he
who least in the kingdom of heaven is
greater than he.
So you have a least and you have a
greater, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, how do you become great in Jesus's
kingdom? Matthew 20 24-28. Matthew 20
24-28.
Okay. Okay, now read with me. Matthew
20:24-28.
Watch here. And when the 10 heard it,
they were greatly displeased with the
two brothers. But Jesus called them to
himself and said, "You know that the
rulers of the Gentiles lorded over them,
and those who are great exercise
authority over them. That's how the
Gentiles rule, right? Yet it shall not
be so among you in my kingdom." That's
not how you're going to act. You will
not be lord over your brother. Yet it
shall not be so among you. But whoever
desires to become great among you, let
him be your servant. Whoever desires to
be first among you, let him be your
slave. Just as a son of man did not come
to be served, but to serve and to give
his life a ransom for many. Do you hear
what he just said? You want to be great
in the kingdom, what should you be on
earth?
>> A servant. So what did you not get?
>> Okay. No, no, I no I no I get it. That
was that was the
>> Jesus says you want to be great in my
kingdom. You want to have a high rank in
my kingdom.
>> You want to be high ranking in my
kingdom and great in my kingdom. Not
least in my kingdom. Be nothing here.
>> Uhhuh. Uhhuh.
>> Be nothing here. Someone tramples over
you, accept it for my sake. Someone
insults you, accept it for my sake.
Consider your brothers and sisters
better than you and serve them without
expecting them to serve you in return
because your reward is with me, not with
them.
And I'll make you great in my kingdom.
But now here's what's ironic, right?
Didn't Jesus say, "When you do what
you're supposed to do, don't expect
anything because you're doing your duty.
I don't have to reward you."
>> Right? Yeah.
>> But he says, "I'll still reward you
anyway.
Mhm. Right.
>> Is it sinking in?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So, I mean, now there's a reverse, by
the way. Did you know some people's
punishments will be worse than others
depending on the nature of their sin?
There's a flip side on this.
>> I assume so.
>> Yeah. There's a flip side. The positive
side. If you're a believer and you yield
to Jesus and surrender to the spirit and
walk more closely with the spirit and
crucify your flesh and deny your sinful
passions and serve others and love
others and put them ahead of yourself,
you're going to be great. But then
there's the flip side. The those whose
sins are worse, who've committed more
sins and committed more wicked sins,
their punishment will be worse. So
folks, if you want me to show you that
just like there are rankings in heaven,
there are rankings and degrees of
punishment in hell. Not all will be
punished with the same
degree of severity. You guys want me to
give you the verses on that?
>> I would like that.
>> All right, let me give you the verses.
Who's ready for those verses, guys? All
right. John 19
10 to 11. John 1910 to11.
Guys, get ready. John 19:10 to to 111.
Guys, read with me. Then Pilate said to
him, "Are you not speaking to me? Do you
not know that I have power to crucify
you and power to release you?" Jesus
answered, "You could have no power at
all against me unless it had been given
you from above." Now watch this.
Therefore, the one who delivered me to
you has the greater sin. Has the greater
sin. Did you catch it? Pilot's sin was
bad, but not as bad as the high priest
who handed him over to Pilate.
Everyone got it?
>> Yeah.
>> Before I move on, see what Jesus said to
Pilate? The one who handed me over to
you, his sin is greater than yours. Your
sin is great, but his is greater. His
punishment will be worse.
Focus, guys. Be blessed and learn your
theology. Learn the meat of scripture by
power of the spirit guiding me and
anointing me to speak truth without
error for the glory of Jesus Christ. Pay
attention guys, pay attention. No side
talk. Okay, no side talk. You with me
there? All right, let me show you other
examples. You ready for other examples?
>> Matthew 10:15.
>> Isaiah 53. Don't ask me the same
question 50 times. Matthew 10:15.
Assuredly I say to you guys, pay
attention. Matthew 10:15. Guys, pay
attention. Assuredly, I say to you, it
will be more tolerable, more bearable
for the land of Sodom and Gomorrah in
the day of judgment than for that city.
Did you guys hear what Jesus just said?
I don't think you heard it. He's saying
those cities that heard the gospel,
their punishment will be more severe
than the punishment of Sodom and
Gomorrah. Sodom and Gomorrah, their
punishment will be more bearable than
those cities who've heard the gospel of
Jesus Christ and rejected it.
Did you get what he's saying here?
Matthew 11:20 to 24. Matthew 11 20:24. I
hope you guys being blessed by this
because this is meat, guys. The Holy
Spirit's given us meat, late night meat.
Even though I'm on a diet, not spiritual
diet, though. Matthew 11 20-24. Read.
Read with me. Please read.
Then he began to rebuke the cities in
which most of his mighty works had been
done. Notice the cities where he did
miracles, the cities that saw him do
miracles because they did not repent.
Woe to you.
Woe to you besid for if the mighty works
which were done in in you had been done
where? For the mighty works which had
been done in you had been done in Ty and
Sid Sidum. They would have repented long
ago in sackcloth and ashes. But I say to
you, it will be more tolerable for Ty
and Siden in the day of judgment than
for you. And woe Capernaum were exalted
to heaven that exalts yourself to
heaven. You will be brought down to
Hades. For if the mighty works which
were done in you had been done in Sodom,
it would have remained until this day
Sodom would repent. It would not have
been destroyed. But I say to you that it
shall be more tolerable for the land of
Sodom. For the land of Sodom than for
who? more tolerable for the land of
Sodom and day of judgment than for you.
Did you catch it? Who didn't catch it?
Did you guys catch it?
>> Yes.
>> Sodom and Gomorrah
won't be punished as severely
as the nations that heard the gospel,
saw Jesus do miracles, had the apostles
preach and do miracles, or heard the
gospel and reject it. You understand
what our Lord is saying here?
The nature of your sin and the amount of
sins you committed will affect the
degree of punishment.
You know what is the greatest sin
against God? Hearing the gospel of Jesus
and rejecting it.
Even worse, hearing the gospel of Jesus,
accepting the gospel of Jesus, but then
rejecting the gospel of Jesus, turning
away from Jesus, dying an apostate. Your
punishment is much worse.
Did you get it now?
>> Yes.
>> Luke 12:4748.
And that servant who knew his master's
will and did not prepare himself to or
do according to his will shall be beaten
with many stripes. So if you are a
servant of Jesus and you profess to be
such and you know what his will is and
you don't do it, your blows will be
many, your punishment more severe.
But now notice what it says about those
servants who don't know. Luke 12:47 guys
pay attention. Luke 12:47.
Watch here.
48. Luke 12:4748. Now we read 47. We're
reading 48. Lord Jesus, grant me clarity
of thought. But he who did not know, the
servant who did not know his master's
will, yet committed things deserving of
stripes shall be beaten with few. The
servant who claims to be a servant of
Christ who didn't know Christ's will,
he still will be beaten but with fewer
bolt blows. For everyone to whom much is
given, from him much will be required
and to whom much has been committed. Of
him they will ask the more. So let me
explain what that means practically.
Here I am teaching the Bible, studying
the Bible, proclaiming the Bible, and
given knowledge by the Holy Spirit. If I
fail the Lord, my punishment will be
much more severe
than Abdullah's punishment, who doesn't
know much as me and has been teaching as
long as I have.
Now, what does it mean? Watch this. What
does it mean for the servant who didn't
know his master's will and be beaten?
How can a servant not know his master's
will and be accountable for not knowing
it and still being punished? Can I
explain that? Luke 12:48. Can I explain
what that means?
How can the Lord hold the servant
accountable if he didn't know the Lord's
will? You know how he can do that? Can I
explain how? I need you guys to listen
now.
>> Yes, please.
>> Because you have no excuse for your
ignorance. The moment you say you are a
Christian,
that means you're aware Jesus is Lord
and he's given you a church and he's
given you a Bible. Why aren't you
picking up and studying it? Whose fault
is it? Whose fault is it
that you have not picked up his word and
studied his word or pursued his word and
sought his word to know his word? Whose
fault is it? That's why you still be
held accountable. The moment you say,
"I'm a Christian," whether you say, "I'm
a Catholic orthodox," Jesus is going to
say, "Come here. Did you not say you
were a Christian? Did you not say that
you're a follower of Jesus? Did you not
say that you belong to this tradition on
the Orthodox church or the Catholic
Church? So, you bore witness that you
knew me. But wait, as a Christian, did
you not know there was a church, a
church that taught you my word, the
Bible? So, why were you ignorant of my
will when you knew where my will was to
be found?
You have no excuse.
That's what he's saying.